Yeah, as Aga mentioned, my name is Houssein,
and I will be talking today about performance
empathy.
Empathy's a term we commonly use to describe
the ability to understand and share the feelings
of another individual or a group.
I like to think of the term "performance empathy"
to be the same thing, but for the performance
concerns and issues of a particular site.
To explain why I thought it would be a good
topic for a talk, I need first to describe
a bit more about myself.
I work as an advocate for the web team at
Google.
Now, developer-advocates in many different
companies usually act as a bridge between
a specific engineering community and a specific
engineering team and a developer community.
Being an advocate for the web team means that
it's my job to make sure the web gets better
and better.
I focus on speed and performance.
So a lot of advocates, we sometimes give advice
that can seem a little overwhelming.
I don't know why my clicker feels weird!
There you go.
[Scattered laughter].
But in all seriousness why are so many performance
advocates fascinated about what they do with
their own tool chains?
Why are we so focused whether it will improve
performance or not?
Why do we care performance that much to begin
with?
Is it really that much of a problem?
To help us answer this question, let's look
at this example of a site.
It's an entirely client-side rendered site
that ships a megabyte of JavaScript.
This means that the initial request only contains
a shell of an HTML document.
Only after the JavaScript bundle finishes
executing, the user gets to see any real content.
Now, in case you weren't counting, the amount
of time it took for this app to finish loading
was about 19 seconds.
19 seconds isn't fast by any means.
So we know that one megabyte of JavaScript
can seem like a lot to ship town to browsers.
How much are we generally shipping?
If we take a look at the HTTP archive, we
can see the median amount of JavaScript we
are sending down the wire is about 350 kilobytes,
and this for mobile web pages.
The reason this is such a big deal is because
a lot of websites currently living in the
web that are either entirely static or they
have little to no interactivity at all.
I thought it would be interesting to dive
in a little deeper and see how much how much
site they use of a particular framework are
shipping in terms of JavaScript.
And I did it with three frameworks to begin
with: Angular, React, and Vue.
The reason I chose these three is because
they are the most popular client-side frameworks
today to build our UI.
I found out after querying 250,000 origins,
about 50 per cent of them ship over a megabyte
of JavaScript.
Now, each of these origins either use one
or more of these frameworks.
There's a lot of reasons why this might be
the case, but it does show that we are shipping
a lot of JavaScript if we are not entirely
careful.
Now, what I want to do now is take a step
back and talk about how I began the presentation.
You see, every single talk I've ever given
before today has always followed the exact
same format: I begin with a word of caution,
and talk about how performance is a pretty
big problem.
I then move on to showing some stats and some
numbers to back up my claim, and I do this
to convey how much of a problem this actually
is.
And then the rest of my talk usually follows
the same sort of pattern where I talk about
different tips, different techniques, that
you should be applying to make sure your site
stays as small as possible and as fast as
possible.
For this talk, I'm going to go in a slightly
different direction.
I want to talk about what we can do as advocates,
and what we can do better to reach the community
better, as well as how we can all work together
to try and think of different ways to to make
sure performance is a win for everybody.
Going back to that example of a site we just
talked about, here I mentioned that, at the
end, I mentioned that we are running this
on a mobile device and a slow 3G connection.
A lot of people when they trace performance,
they talk about specific user conditions that
might not be the same as yours when you build
your application.
And we do this because the fending on the
user's device or network type, they can experience
your site a lot slower than you think.
And there's more.
We sometimes talk about how your users might
experience your site if they're completely
offline, or if they have a flaky network connection,
or maybe they have a weaker device, on mobile,
so forth, and so on.
Although it is important to talk about all
these scenarios and try to capture different
conditions your user might be in, the thing
I want to make sure I mention is that you
know your users better than anyone else.
You definitely know your users better than
any advocate that stands on stage telling
you how well your site performs under a certain
condition.
That being said, one thing I want also to
mention is the fact that nobody prioritises
performance over anything.
If you think about it, when you're trying
to build a site, the very first thing you're
thinking about usually isn't performance.
Most people are like this.
But if you also think about it, why should
someone make it the very top thing they think
about?
Let's talk about something to try and complain
what I mean here.
Say you wake up one Monday morning and you
have an amazing idea.
You've thought about a product you want to
sell on the website or maybe you want to provide
a specific type of service.
So you're excited, and the next thing you
naturally do is try to find out how to build
it.
You spend a little time researching the tools,
the tips, the tricks that you need, maybe
you're building wire frames, maybe building
graphics, so forth and so on, but only after
that, you actually start building.
And at this point, throughout the initial
process, nobody really thinks about performance.
The thing that you actually most likely are
thinking about is the fact that you want to
build a site that loads and does exactly what
you expect it to do, but build it with as
minimal effort and as fast as possible.
A second possible scenario could be the fact
that you join a brand new team as a developer.
Say the newest developer on a brand new team,
and, when you get assigned your first ticket,
you're most likely going to try and familiarise
yourself with the code base.
You will spend a little time trying to know
where your components live, where the utilities
live, how the unit tests work, and so on.
Only after that, while you're doing that,
you start building and working on your first
feature.
Maybe it's a small feature you're adding on
a page, maybe it's a small bug that you're
working on.
But again, also, when you're in these shoes,
you're not thinking about performance.
You're not think about what I'm building doesn't
degrade the performance of my site.
No, it's the first thing you're doing, most
likely trying to check every single box assigned
to you.
It's highly unlikely performance is on that
list.
The way I like to think about awareness and
performance in general, and how people are
aware of the performance and location of the
site, I try to think of it as some sort of
scale.
For example, let's say you're building something
for the first time, or you're building something
for the umpteenth time which you're learning
a brand new tool.
What you're going to be doing at this point
is seeing how this tool works.
Does it do what you expect it to do?
You're going to learn the API, is it easy
to plug into your site?
At this point, it's unlikely you're unlikely
thinking how badly it's going to affect your
performance.
You're thinking how easy is it for me to use?
Let me spend some more time with that, and
after a while, you end up launching your first
website.
You have an idea of how it works in development
mode and how it works in production mode.
You have a better feeling whether it is really
affecting performance or not, but you still
might be slightly unsure of what you need
to do about it.
But the more and more you use this tool, and
the more websites that you build, the more
familiar you are with how it affects the speed
and reliability of your site.
That being said, nobody is more aware with
the fact that they need to work on performance
than those that actually know they have issues.
If a significant per cent of your user base
tells you we can't access your site because
it's too slow, you're most likely going to
try and prioritise it as soon as possible.
This is what I mean by performance being an
afterthought.
Maybe there are ways out there of it being
not of something we only think of when it
is too late.
Throughout this talk, I sort of this this
dichotomy between two different users groups,
one being performance advocates like myself,
and one being a normal developer working on
a regular codebase.
Now, advocates, I think we all agree on the
fact that there are way too many slow sites,
and the reason why I think this is true is
because we have our job because a lot of the
sites out there aren't as fast as they should
be.
If every user accesses the website and felt
like it was faster than it needed to be, we
wouldn't need to be doing what we do every
day.
But there's another misconception, or another
thought that sometimes gets misconstrued that
seems kind of weird, and it's the idea that
developers are sloppy when they ship slow
experience.
I've seen the sentiment time to time, and
I can't understand it, because a developer
working on a website, and it happens too bad
too slow, it is usually one of three reasons.
One, they don't know it is too slow for their
users, two, they know it's too slow but they
don't know how to fix it, or they haven't
prioritised that yet, and, three, they know
it's too slow and they're actively working
to effectively.
Indeed again is always relative.
Having an advocate tell you that you're not
focusing on something very important to them
isn't always the best approach.
Now, on the other side of the coin, when we
talk about a developer, when you're building
a website, you're most likely going to agree
that you have a million things you can work
on.
Performance is just one of them.
But it's also another weird thought that I
see sometimes floating around and it's the
idea that advocates, or performance advocates,
specifically, are out of touch.
The reason why some people might think this
is because of the fact that many performance
advocates will build small sample apps and
show you how to optimise and some people will
feel it's not easy to do it with a massive
codebase and a massive team where code is
being checked in everywhere.
The reason why I want to squash this thought
is because advocates have been in your shoes.
We are developers.
We worked with teams who understand that there
are more concerns to a site than there is
just performance.
Instead of having the back-and-forth between
small weird opinions and small, small thoughts,
I think it's safe to say we all agree towards
one common goal: we all want the web to be
faster for everybody.
So the big question is: how can we make sure
we can fix the performance problem better?
What I'm going to do is talk about a few ways
we can explore that, because there are changing
sort of how we think about making things better
for our developers.
The very first is making sure everybody has
better defaults.
What I mean by default is the idea is that
let's say you're building something with a
certain tool.
If it always gives you a better starting point,
you will most likely always have more wiggle
room, and more room to play with where it
will take you longer to reach a threshold
or performance and end up being slow.
And in terms of framework level, a lot of
frameworks are looking into this already.
React has already been looking to try to improve
React DOM and make the sites smaller.
Doing this a few different ways, one of them
being simplifying its event system.
With Vue and Vue3, they are looking to reduce
memory function and making things more tree-shakeable
where they can.
The Angular team is looking into building
brand new rendering engine called Ivy, and
with it exploring ways to cut down the initial
bundle size and also looking at ways of maybe
progressively heightening experiences when
you have server render architectures.
React and Suspense is also doing the same
thing.
And then there are metaframeworks, things
like Next.js that allow you to do what you
want to do most of the time, write and build
your component.
There are things that we tell people to do
quite often.
You should be code - these frameworks take
it out of the hands of the develop.
Developer.
We are already working with XJS to see if
we can do things even better and even have
smaller bundle sizes and make sure users get
the best experience wherever they can.
When we talk about defaults, the only way
to think about it too is the default APIs
or the out-the-box APIs that the browser provides.
It will be a lot easier if we didn't have
to leverage third-party libraries or write
scripts ourselves when we try to optimise
things that the browser can probably do already.
An example of this is the lazy-loading attribute.
Now, if anybody here is actually building
something with a lot of images, you most likely
realise that having a lot of images load at
once can affect performance, so people have
become quite used to either pulling in a third-party
library or writing their own custom script
that takes advantage of the intersection observer
API or scroll-event listers to only add listers
to those close enough to them.
The loading attribute is something that will
be rolled out to Chrome pretty soon, and by
using it with any image or iFrame tag, it
will automatically lazy-load images after
it reaches a certain distance threshold from
the bottom of the viewport.
Think about the wins this can make to any
developer.
Think about the main developers that don't
know how to build their own lazy-loading scripts
or even know if there is such a thing, but
once they realise there is a simple app they
can add, it will make it a lot simpler for
everybody.
Another example of an API that makes things
easier is the virtual scrolling API that is
also being worked on right now.
If you've ever built anything, a site with
a long table, or very large list, you also
realise that having all those DOM nodes populate
at once can affect rendering performance.
And the idea behind this virtualisation or
virtual scrolling is to make sure that only
the nodes or only the items on the list that
the user can see is populated through DOM,
and as the user scrolls down, those DOM nodes
get recycled with newer DOM nodes.
A lot of frameworks like React, like Angular,
have third-party libraries that allow you
a virtualised list.
Having a bake-in API means you can do this
without relying on any of them at all at all.
For example, accessibility concerns, or the
find on page feature, or how could SDO crawl
your page, or a crawler crawl your page, and
detect things that are not rendered to the
DOM just yet?
Another very important thing we also realise
is in general, we need better guardrails for
all developers.
We've noticed a pattern where we tell people
to optimise, and a lot of teams will go ahead
and they will start doing so.
After a certain period of time, feature creep
is in, new code is being shipped, or they
regress to the initial state or the state
worse than prior.
The idea behind guardrails is what if you
had something that made sure everybody stayed
accountable and made sure everybody stayed
on a narrow path?
One such example of a guardrail is a performance
budget.
A performance budget is a budget for certain
performance metrics that you make sure your
app never exceeds.
There are many tools out there that can allow
you to add performance budgets.
One such example of those recently launched
was something called Lighthouse, a team built
by the Chrome team that allows you to audit
how well your pages are doing.
It allows to check for accessibility, performance,
and so on.
A lot of developers use Lighthouse every day
in their work flow, and the idea is what if
you can specify a single JSON file to add
performance budgets into it?
You can specify different resource types,
define the budget that you never exceed, as
well as the defined third-party request and
make sure the number of requests never exceeds
a certain value.
The third most important point, and I think
this is something that actually resonates
with me quite well, is the fact that we need
to meet develops where they are.
As an advocate, if we are telling developers
that they need to change their entire work
flow, or the tools that they're using isn't
going to work and they have to swap it out
for another, we're not going to go very far.
And it's something I've seen more and more
of right now.
What I'm trying to do is trying to improve
the fact that whatever tool you decide to
use, whatever framework or library you decide
to use, what if we could always make sure
that tools stays and performant as it possibly
can?
And in terms of how we are trying to do this
one way is through tooling.
And there is a feature called Stack Back.
This extends to Lighthouse but in a different
way.
The idea behind Stack Pack is that it allows
Lighthouse to detect what tools are being
run on your page and then give specific recommendations
specific to that room.
Let's say you're using WordPress to build
a site, and you're working out how to properly
side your images.
You can read a highly generalised advice that
will apply to anyone, but see advice that
is more specific to you.
You see how to do it using the WordPress.
The idea with Stack Pack, we try to roll this
out to many Java frameworks and CMS tools.
WordPress is the only one that is supported
right now.
Documentation is always going to be a big
deal, and it's going to be a big deal for
a while.
Now, in Google and the Chrome team, we have
a lot of documentation at a high level, generalised,
and they work for the main developers as they
possibly can.
They're trying to roll out frameworks-specific
guidance.
This is a new documentation site that we have
that is more interactive and specific to the
user, and recently launched a whole section
on frameworks.
The idea is we're not - the idea is we're
not trying to teach you how to use a tool
like React, we are trying to show you how
you can make your React app as fast as possible
using in-built React APIs and third-party
libraries in the React ecosystem.
We plan on having more Angular View and other
frameworks in the future.
In the Chrome team we've also been doing in
terms of monitoring support.
Malte and Nicole announced this and mentioned
something called framework fund.
A lot of people working in open source, a
lot of developers in open source, and how
can we support them in more than one way,
to continue to try to increase performance
of their tools or those who use them will
get better defaults, better guardrails, and
more.
When it comes to fixing the performance problem,
I think as advocates, we are doing it in two
sort of ways, one being which I call internal
support.
We write blogs to tell you how to do things.
We build third-party libraries that you can
plug in through sites.
We give talks at a place like JSConf and tell
you what you need to do to improve the speed
your site.
Then the internal side of things.
How does the tool you're using get better
by default?
What if they get better at a starting point?
What if they have better guidance and better
warnings?
As of now, I currently feel we're more so
on the external side, and that's fine.
We will continue to do that as long as we
can reach more developers can we possibly
can.
What I would like to see in the next few years
is a shift in the other direction.
In an ideal world, we wouldn't have to tell
developers what to do if every tool they're
using already does it automatically.
I hope you enjoyed this talk as much as I
enjoyed giving it.
Thank you.
[Applause].